foreign
folks full disclosure I'm seeing it the
same time you are well uh let's see what
the internet is is stirring up today
when it comes to real estate investing
and why this is the best asset class
this is about as simple as I can make it
we're doing a light rehab and my
flooring guy asked me said Jason why are
you all in on real estate and why are
you not investing in stocks and Bitcoin
I said that's a great question Mike do
you have a 401k I asked him he said yes
I have 200 000 in my 401k I said great
job that's better than most scenario
number one your dad gets sick you have
to take him to a nursing home their
charging seven thousand dollars a month
to keep them there with your two hundred
thousand dollars in your 401k how long
can you keep them there he thought about
it for a moment 28 and a half months
that's not a long time for being in a
nursing home scenario number two your
dad gets sick you still got to take him
to the nursing home and they're still
charging seven thousand dollars a month
but instead of having 200 thousand
dollars in a 401k account you took that
200 Grand and bought 10 cash flowing
assets that produced ten thousand
dollars a month how long can you keep
them there he thought about it and said
forever and that's the power of Real
Estate
all right well that was a fast moving
hard charging real estate Guru right
there Ken yeah and this is the problem
with the tick tock World we're in
YouTube I love it we're on all the
things okay but it's like if I'm gonna
take something and that complex
that serious
and I'm going to reduce it to a bunch of
jump Cuts in a video and go when it's
done like I've just taken care of your
day come on this is this is Click bait
stuff oh this is this is cotton candy
what got me sadly a lot of people are
like oh yeah you're right I gotta dump
my 401k and go buy a property right now
this is essentially what he just said
this guy probably has a whole lot more
knowledge and experience I don't want to
bang on this guy because I you say
anything in this world now this is going
to go out there and then yeah we said
something one time about somebody who
gave silly advice
and and the lady wanted to debate me
online
I I got news for you I don't care what
you think
this segment involves what I think and
what I think is this is Click bait it is
surface advice that can get people
really hurt George you know this why
well what happens when you take that
advice and you don't know what you're
doing so this whole fast talking thing
is to get you to do basically nothing
down real estate it's like down as
little as possible cash flowing assets
what that's the hot ticket item right
there Ken if you hear that online run
those guys have an online course to sell
you I promise you he does cash flowing
assets that's what it's all about don't
invest your 401k you got to get nothing
down real estate because then your
tenants will just pay your mortgage and
you'll be a millionaire in no time yeah
no brainer you can't jump cut your way
to financial success that's what that
was tweet that there you go whoever's on
Twitter who's that whoever is left over
there well here's the deal Ken yes I
thought that was pretty good he totally
faked the scenario where the flooring
guy is going hey why why aren't you
investing completely yeah the flooring
that never happened second of all this
weird thing about what if your dad's in
the nursing home and you got to pay for
the nursing home I don't understand why
that's the scenario he goes to but it's
called long-term care George we always
recommend long-term care uh because of
that scenario so talk to your parents if
you've got someone who's in the elderly
stage and they may be going you've got
to get long-term care in place to cover
this number one and we don't know Dad
may have a bunch of retirement why is
this on you don't set your kids up in
that way to where they've got a tank
their 401k and the other point I have is
that at your 401k creates cash it's
invested and with an average by the way
eight ten twelve percent it makes money
and you can get as close to a guarantee
with that you can't guarantee that
you're going to be able to buy 10 houses
and they turn into all this that you're
talking about because you're talking
about spinning off rent oh and the
renters just magically pay perfectly
every month and don't damage the place
in the HVAC and the roof and everything
just stays perfectly fine yeah so let's
what do you think the average you know
what let's have some fun with this
George
strategy which by the way the only thing
missing on the end of that video was hey
buy my product so you can buy your dad a
castle on the beach with a hot nurse I
mean that literally was the last thing
needed we may have cut them off early he
may have gone into that yeah it might
have gone into that uh what do you think
average person running that strategy
what do you think they're making on rent
well you gotta imagine they've got 500
bucks they've got very little equity in
the property yeah they've got the
mortgage to pay right plus maintenance
plus HOA plus expenses plus their
insurance and after that their net
profit is very well but let's just pick
a number to to because what I don't want
to do is critique this and not help you
see the other side of it so let's say
they're making between George you're the
math guy most people 100 to 800 bucks
you're clearing that you think they're
clearing that that's right from callers
that call in who have investment
property with mortgages on it they say
well we're making about 10 grand on it
would you say so the net would be
between five and eight hundred bucks
that's fair all right so times 12 months
yeah so you're talking six grand eight
grand versus ten Grand versus investing
money in a 401k over the same amount of
time well you got 200 bucks on a 401K
and you get a return of 10 on that 200k
that's 20 grand that year that you
didn't have to do anything by the way
yeah you have to mop the floor talk to a
tenant who's got more cats than they do
since I mean you don't have to do that I
mean this is real numbers absolutely and
here's the thing we love real estate
around here Dave's got a lot of it but
he paid cash for it which changes the
way you view it and it the return on
that investment is astronomical compared
to you trying to keep up and pay the
mortgage and net profit on that thing
and so you want to talk about cash
flowing assets pay cash for that
investment property and add up what that
amounts to it see that's not in the
video the video doesn't explain how it
takes for all that rental income to
equal this the amount of money that he's
promising absolutely and the risk
involved
so here's the deal the more boring it
sounds the more I'm excited about it
because I feel like oh I could do that
when it comes to handling you know 10
pieces of real estate with nothing down
that's a lot of anxiety in my life while
trying to work a full-time job here's an
old old saying and I don't know who said
it George
if it looks or sounds too good to be
true
it probably is and that's the
click-baity stuff that we got to be
careful about how in the world can
someone give you this unbelievable sound
financial advice in a one minute Tick
Tock or whatever it ends up being I just
I will tell you folks it's cotton candy
well Our advice hey once you're out of
debt and have an emergency fund invest
15 into your 401k sounds boring and
guess what it's the number one
investment vehicle to becoming a
millionaire based on the 10 000 that we
studied
do with that information what you will
and by the way you can have a great 401k
and invest in real estate with cash and
a nice cardigan and a great cardigan to
match there you go